et's social study what the stars are  posting online Cindy Crawford has the  perfect baby shower gift for a mall and  George Clooney you guys have names  everything picked out and my wife said I  can't name them Casas and amigos that's  the one thing I'm not allowed to do here  Cindy holding up cute casa and me goes  onesies the name of the tequila company  Clooney has with her husband Randy  Gerber naturally we couldn't help but  notice the pink and blue lettering which  could be a hint at the gender of their  twins just a thought  yeah it's a family business moving on  Victoria Beckham announced she's getting  in the passenger seat with James Corden  so we are here  Oh  [Music]  while many Spice Girls fans rejoice at  the return of posh spice one Twitter  user was disappointed that Victoria  chose to sing on the show but didn't  agree to a Spice Girls reunion  [Music]  you